Britt: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out the differences
between Hungry Jack's Australia
and Burger King in the US.
This is "Food Wars."
First things first.
You might have noticed there's
a difference in the name.
Here in Australia,
Burger King operates under
the name Hungry Jack's
because when they first came here,
their name was already taken.
We'll get more into the history later,
but when you hear me saying
Hungry Jack's, that's why.
Now let's get into the drinks.
In Australia, our Hungry Jack's drinks
come in three sizes,
small, medium, and large.
In the US, our Burger King
drinks come in four sizes.
The value, the small,
the medium, and the large.
Let's measure them to keep them honest.
To be fair to Burger
King, I filled these up.
I think I did a pretty good job.
The lid's a little recessed.
Yes, there's ice in there.
Britt: Now let's measure the large.
Joe: I feel like everything
is about 4 or 5 ounces off.
Our fries, or chips, as we
like to call them in Australia,
come in three sizes,
small, medium, and large.
Our fries come in four sizes.
The little value, the small,
the medium, and the large.
And you know we're gonna weigh 'em.
So, these portions should weigh 90 grams,
116 grams, and 166 grams,
according to the Hungry Jack's website.
So let's see if this is true.
That's convenient.
Both Australia and the
US have the Whopper,
so let's weigh both of them and compare.
All right.
On to the nuggets.
In Australia, our nuggets
come in four sizes,
three, six,
12, and 18.
Our US nuggets come
technically in three sizes,
the four-piece; the eight-piece,
which, in some parts of the country
you can also get the fiery
nugget version in eight-piece;
and a 16-piece, which was not available.
Well, I want to be in the shot.
I'm just kidding.
Because this is my new headshot.
Here in the US, we have
four sizes of onion rings.
Again, value, small, medium, and large.
In Australia, our onion
rings come in two sizes,
a medium and a large.
Just eyeballing it right now,
looks like we have bigger
portion sizes than Australia.
I'm going to count out
the rings in the largest
and see how it compares to theirs.
Britt: So, in a large serving,
we get 12 onion rings.
OK, so this, this is one
of the smaller ones we had.
Here is everything that you'll find
at an Australian Hungry Jack's
that you won't find in
an American Burger King.
And here's everything you can get
at a Burger King/Hungry Jack's in America
that you can't get in Australia.
Let's get into the burgers.
I have to say, my
observation in all of this
is all of these burgers,
not only are they massive,
but they look really good.
We have a Whiskey River Whopper.
You've got onion, you've got lettuce,
you have chips inside, you have tomatoes.
Two layers of cheese,
two burger patties.
I really like this. I
really, really like this.
The burgers are better at Hungry Jack's!
So, there's a saying in Australia,
it's one of their slogans,
and they always say,
"The burgers are better at Hungry Jack's."
And this is really good.
I can't taste whiskey specifically.
I don't know if it's ...
I'm not drunk yet.
So I think there's not whiskey in there,
but I think it must be,
like, a whiskey glaze
or a whiskey sauce.
It's like a caramelized flavor.
We have these exclusive US burgers,
starting all the way down there.
A Texas double Whopper. Same
as a regular double Whopper,
but this one has jalapeños.
Tejas.
OK, so you're getting your money's worth.
Oh, there's also bacon
in there too? All right.
Pretty good. I don't know
if I could eat a whole one
of those, but I like that.
We have a double Whiskey River Whopper,
an ultimate double Whopper,
which is two layers of beef
and two layers of cheese.
We have your classic Whopper,
a double Whopper and cheese,
a triple Whopper and cheese,
and an Angry Whopper.
And it comes with a single
patty or a double patty,
or there's a triple-beef
option if that's what you like.
And with angry onions.
I don't know what an angry onion is.
I've never met an angry onion before.
All right, let's have a
bite of the Angry Whopper.
There's a bit of a spice to it.
Nothing too overpowering.
It's quite nice. I like this as well.
But that's really, like,
a nice subtle kick to it.
So that's what makes it
angry, if you were wondering.
I'm so happy I could solve
that problem for you,
because I'm here to serve.
If double meat isn't enough for you,
we also have the triple
Whopper, Australia.
Yes, you are correct. That is a bun,
then a piece of meat, and
then another piece of meat,
and then a third piece of meat,
and then all the stuff.
You just jump in the middle of the meat.
You can't just go meat, meat, meat.
Our Whopper doesn't
automatically have cheese.
You can get a Whopper
with cheese, obviously.
So this one doesn't have cheese.
Texas did have cheese.
I don't know why cheese isn't
the default for the Whopper.
The Whopper has been around for so long,
back when people wanted regular hamburgers
and not cheeseburgers, which
I think is just insanity.
And then we have the bacon deluxe.
This is very similar to the
ultimate double Whopper.
The sizing is the main
difference that I can tell,
and obviously with the patties and stuff,
but the flavor is supposed to be the same.
We also have the barbecue
bacon Whopper Jr.,
which of course has bacon, American bacon.
Now's the perfect time.
I know that she was talking
about close-up of the bacon,
so why don't I just do a little
something right here for her?
All right. All right,
check it out, Australia.
American bacon.
We got the strip bacon.
Let's get a good glamour
shot. Now we're big.
Look at the strips! We got the strips.
So, the bacon in Hungry Jack's
is Australian eye bacon,
and it looks something like this,
if you can manage to see
it past all this sauce.
I know you guys in
America generally prefer
your bacon to be a bit
crispier and thinner.
We do have that option here.
However, our rashers of bacon
do tend to be quite a thicker portion.
So it is thin and crispy on the outside,
but the inside, see how it's, like, a,
it's a nice bit of pork?
Speaking of bacon, we have the bacon king.
It feels like it's just the
Whopper without the vegetables,
which I applaud.
Look, everyone, they put
cheese in between the meat.
See? They know how to
do it. This is great.
I don't know why this has
to be a whole different
menu thing. Just call this the —
this should be the Whopper.
And then we have a Whopper Jr. and cheese,
little baby Whopper,
and then a triple cheeseburger
and a barbecue cheeseburger.
Moving on to the much smaller burgers.
Look at this, man. These
are tiny little guys.
Bacon cheeseburger.
If you want a little
more meat in your mouth,
and you know I do,
go ahead and get yourself the double.
Yo, Australia!
Look at that cheese pull.
It's like an Insider video
from three years ago.
I have no idea what rodeo,
if rodeos exist outside of
the States or the Americas.
And if they don't, we have
a thing called rodeos.
And for some reason we
have a Rodeo Burger,
and that's just a cheeseburger
with barbecue sauce and onion rings.
And now we have our
Grill Master collection.
So, this is made from
thick, juicy Angus.
Starting off to my right,
we have the Grill Masters
pulled pork and Angus.
They went hard on the pulled pork.
They didn't shy away from that.
You can taste the barbecue sauce,
which is surprising because it didn't look
like there was much barbecue sauce on it.
The pork flavor's coming
through ever so slightly.
But it's just the texture
of the pulled pork
and a solid beef patty that
I don't really like that much.
We have our Grill Master cowboy Angus.
We have our Grill Master
double cowboy Angus,
with two Angus patties.
And then we have our Grill
Masters Chicago Angus patty.
Double bacon, natural
cheese, and peppercorn sauce.
I'm also curious to know, like,
why do they make a Chicago burger?
What is a Chicago burger?
Is Chicago a peppery city?
I thought it was the Windy City.
It has a patty, it's got some
lettuce, iceberg lettuce,
a sauce, which I presume
has pepper in it, obviously,
otherwise, don't know what
that black stuff is in it.
That would be questionable.
And it has a layer of cheese
and bacon and tomatoes.
I think maybe the reason
it's a Chicago-style burger
is because of the double bacon.
I know in the early part of last century
the stockyards were
really popular in Chicago.
Upton Sinclair wrote a book
about it called "The Jungle."
Don't read it. It's a real bummer.
This is — I prefer this to that.
This has a lot more flavor.
The textures are good.
I like the combination of
the bacon and the Angus beef.
It's really messy, though,
so don't take someone out on a first date
and get the Chicago burger.
And now we have our Grill
Masters Angus, bacon, and cheese
and then the Grill Masters
double Angus, bacon, and cheese.
So there's two Angus patties
and two layers of cheese.
I just have to say I'm really
impressed by Hungry Jack's.
I find that their burgers
are really, really good,
and the quality is unreal.
Here are all the chicken options
exclusive over here in the US.
Down here, we have the
BK royal crispy chicken.
Royal.
The Burger King royal, the BK royal.
Fit for King ...
Philip? Charles.
Australia, I don't know if
you're aware of this, but there's
a chicken-sandwich civil war
going on in this country.
Every single fast-food place
has their chicken sandwich.
I think Chick-fil-A just
came in, got everyone scared.
Every fast-food place, every burger place
has at least four chicken
sandwiches, sometimes more.
And Burger King, I gotta
say they did a good job.
Been sitting for a minute, still crispy.
Very impressive. Crispy's in the title.
Here are all the chicken options
that you can get at Hungry Jack's.
The Whiskey River Jack's fried chicken.
So, you have some lettuce,
you have your whiskey sauce
with some chips, onion ring maybe?
The spicy BK royal crispy chicken sando.
Generous with the mayo.
They're moving mayo at
BK. They're moving mayo.
Everything is chicken
with mayo. I don't mind.
It's got more heat than
I thought it would.
Nothing I can't handle, but yeah.
The Whiskey River grilled chicken,
the classic Jack's fried chicken.
This is just fried chicken
with some mayonnaise
and some iceberg lettuce.
This spicy Jack's fried chicken,
and it has spicy sauce on that.
Australia, we also have a bacon and Swiss
BK royal crispy chicken
sandwich, and here it is.
That's good. It's a good
combo. That's really good.
I like that.
I probably would get that
one over all the other ones.
The cheesy bacon classic
Jack's fried chicken,
the cheesy bacon spicy
Jack's fried chicken.
So, this would be the spicy sauce.
That's a lot of spicy sauce.
The spicy grilled chicken,
the grilled chicken,
the grilled chicken with bacon and cheese.
And of course this little
guy, the chicken Jr.
If you've ever had a McChicken,
it's the same exact thing.
Whoa, what's going on here?
Is that sauce, or is that, like ... ?
Started skimping on —
no, because mayo's on top.
So what's that?
I'm not licking it!
Maybe it is mayo. I don't know what it is.
I want to try the cheesy bacon
spicy Jack's fried chicken
because I haven't been
able to get a spicy burger,
and this looks like it is
packed with spice.
So let's take a bite into it and see
how spicy it really is.
That is very spicy.
Definitely recommend this one.
This one's really, really good.
It's such a relief,
because I feel like every
burger that we've had is, like,
says it's spicy, but it's like, where?
And last but not least,
we have some additional exclusive items!
At the Burger King, we have a big fish,
which is our fish sandwich.
Rivals, of course the Filet-O-Fish.
A square piece of fish.
Looks a little rough,
right? I like how it tastes.
Filet-O-Fish is better, but
I'd get down on a big fish.
Remember those chicken
sandwiches from before?
We got them in wrap form.
Three wraps to choose from.
So, the first one we have is the
classic crispy — ee! Wrap, sorry.
Half a chicken breast.
Half? Come on, guys.
Did you really just cut it in half?
Can't give us the whole one?
Mayo, lettuce, tomato. Nope.
This one's a spicy one.
Here's the other half.
And again, half a chicken wrap.
I don't know what the price point is,
but you're definitely
getting half of the chicken
you're getting in sandwich form.
We do have a couple of plant-based options
at our Burger King.
They're not vegan though,
because they're cooked on the
same grill as the beef burgers
and still contain dairy and eggs.
Just, ah, Burger King, mwah on that one.
The Impossible Whopper,
which we have here.
There's also the single Impossible king.
Couldn't get it for this one.
"What does the burger taste
like?" you ask, Australia.
Well, first of all, let's
take a look at it. Eeee.
Sometimes it looks like beef,
and sometimes, like now, it does not.
It has mayo on here, and I'm
certain it's not a vegan mayo.
It tastes just like a Whopper.
Because a Whopper is swimming in mayo,
and they add something to the meat
to make it taste like it's char-grilled.
I mean, I think that everything together,
because of the toppings and the way
that they prepare a Whopper
and an Impossible Whopper are the same,
so I would think, yeah,
maybe side by side I
could tell a difference,
but right now this tastes
exactly like a Whopper.
But if we just isolate the meat,
you can taste a difference
in just the meat, so.
Not my favorite.
If you're a vegetarian or a vegan,
well, get it without the mayo.
If you're not eating meat,
I would say that the
plant-based Whopper, to me,
is probably the closest to the real thing
as far as plant-based
fast-food things are concerned.
That's my personal opinion.
We actually have two plant-based burgers
and a fully vegan burger.
The vegan Whopper and
cheese, double vegan patty,
vegan cheese, vegan mayo,
and the patty is made from veg.
We have a plant-based Whopper,
a plant-based Whopper cheese.
The cheese is not vegan. The
plant-based Angry Whopper.
Our vegan options are actually vegan,
as they're cooked separately
from the meat patties,
which is really good,
because if you're a vegan or a vegetarian
and you want to come and get a good feed,
then you know it's definitely vegan.
This is the best place to go to.
Yeah, so, "Have a good feed"
in Australian means ...
how do I even say it? A good feed.
Like, enjoy your meal. If
you want to have a good meal.
If you want to enjoy your meal.
Let's try this vegan Whopper
cheese. Double vegan patty.
This is a good option.
If you did want an
alternative, I like this.
And if you just didn't want any meat,
it's very filling,
there's a lot of flavor.
It's got a herby taste to it.
You can taste the onion.
The cheese is good too.
I just want to try the cheese separately
just to see if that adds any flavor.
The cheese is just a bit
creamy. Creamy texture.
A bit more of a smoky flavor,
subtle smoky flavor throughout.
On to the sides.
Australia, you don't
have these chicken fries?
Get a load of this.
Isn't this a great idea?
Looks like a fry, right?
Nah, nah, nah, nah, nah.
This is a piece of chicken.
They come in, I don't know
how many different options.
We got the four-piece,
and it came in a bag.
It usually comes in a fun
little box, but whatever.
These things are fantastic.
Mozzarella sticks,
come in four and eight pieces.
No way I can do this pull.
These have been sitting for a minute.
Wait ...
Yo ... no. Comes with marinara sauce.
Our BK also has applesauce,
but they unfortunately forgot it.
So no sauce.
And in Australia, these
are our exclusive sides.
We have a three nuggets
and chip carry cup,
and we have a pop'n chick'n carry cup
and a pop'n chick'n carry cup 20-pack.
However, those were not available.
But we do have a load of other sauces.
You know what that means! Sauce talk.
Sauce talk.
Now we're going to talk
about all the sauces we have
that are exclusive to
Australian Hungry Jack's,
starting with a barbecue plum sauce.
Aioli. And aioli's not just garlic mayo.
Traditionally it's made
with garlic and olive oil,
whereas mayo uses oil and egg yolks.
And then we have our spicy sauce.
How spicy is it?
I'm about to tell you right now
because I'm going to crack into this.
Let's go.
It's not that spicy.
The kick comes after. It is spicy.
Barbecue plum. Never heard
of a barbecue plum before.
That's really good!
It's sweet. It's got that sweet plum,
kind of jam, marmalade flavor,
but with that barbecue sauce through it.
But I feel like the plum
taste comes through more.
I really like that.
All right, barbecue.
Fantastic. Honey mustard.
It's OK. Here's our ranch.
America is obsessed with ranch.
I, of course, am not. But I'll try it.
Yeah, it's fine. All
ranch tastes the same.
Moving out, we got Buffalo sauce.
Pretty good. So, we got
zesty sauce, Australia.
I don't know if this is
just for dipping stuff
or if it's on a burger.
I don't think I've heard of this before.
Maybe we had it before
on other "Food Wars"
and I just don't remember.
Let's see how zesty it is.
Oh, man, that is zesty!
It's like a strong
mustard, but also creamy.
And brown mustard.
Also, we have sweet and sour sauce.
More for nuggets than it is
for fries, but why not, right?
And before, the marinara, you know I love.
We have other sauces you
can get here in the US,
including stacker sauce; mustard and mayo;
tartar sauce; royal sauce,
King Charles' favorite;
and a spicy glaze sauce.
Hungry Jack's also has
some brekkie options.
Just note, brekkie is short for
breakfast here in Australia.
If you're aware, we love
to shorten our words.
So we will call afternoon arvo.
We'll call a snag for a sausage.
Tucker is dinner.
Back to the items here.
Here we have a bacon and
egg Turkish brekkie roll.
We have our sausage and
We have our Jack's brekkie roll,
we have our barbecue brekkie wrap,
and we have our big brekkie wrap,
which is the same as that one.
It just has hash browns in it.
And then we have pancakes.
And on to our cheese toasties.
A cheese toastie. We have
ham and cheese toasties
and a ham, cheese, and tomato toastie.
US, we love our fast-food breakfast,
or brekkie, as you call it in Australia.
Starting down here, we
have French toast sticks.
Frekkies, I guess.
You can get them in three or five.
Has this nice little syrupy dipping sauce.
That's just OK.
We have a lot of breakfast
sandwiches in the US.
You can get a breakfast sandwich
in different bread forms.
The first one we have is a biscuit.
Don't know if you have these in Australia.
Try to explain it to non-Americans
what American biscuits are,
easier just to show you.
You have KFC, right?
It's like those biscuits you get at KFC.
We have these breakfast
sandwiches. See this little thing?
It's, like, the driest thing in the world,
but we have breakfast sandwiches.
Here's a bacon, egg, and cheese one.
You can also get sausage, egg, and cheese;
ham, egg, and cheese.
Good, dry. I really don't go for those,
but what I do like are
the Croissan'wiches,
another bread option
where it is a croissant.
Yes, a croissant, France.
And we stuck a bunch of meat
and cheese inside of it.
Going to go with the,
this one is the bacon one.
A fully loaded, oh, God.
Sausage and ham and bacon.
Oh, my goodness.
Every version of pork in one sandwich
with eggs.
I have to know.
Kind of wish I didn't.
Kind of wish I didn't. Ugh.
Biscuits or croissants. These
are the ones you can get.
I'm going to throw
on-screen the whole list
of both the options that you have.
I can't list them all.
It's just a different version of the bread
with a meat, an egg, and a cheese.
Also they have breakfast
burritos. Believe it.
This one, whoo, yo, dog.
This is a hefty boy.
This I believe is the
Egg-Normous Burrito. Come on.
This thing is, like,
this has gotta be, this is
like a Chipotle burrito.
Look at the size of this thing, Yuelei!
See what's inside.
Australia, I assure
you this is not normal.
Hash browns, bacon, sausage,
an egg, cheese.
And also comes with
a picante salsa, which, we will
find out together how it is.
Breakfast burritos are
a big thing in America,
probably in the UK as well,
but this is just ridiculous.
It's actually really good.
And you know what?
Secret weapon, the salsa.
I don't know who makes
the salsa, but yeah, dude.
I'm having a comeback right now. Mm!
If you want a breakfast
burrito in not-gigantic form,
there's also a breakfast burrito Jr.
Got yourself a sweet tooth?
We have two exclusive desserts in the US.
Right here, two chocolate chip cookies.
Also, we have this Hershey's sundae pie.
Sundae pie on the go.
Look at this thing. Look at this thing!
You see that, Yuelei?
I'm kind of mad now
that I know this exists.
I'm going to want it all the time.
And at Hungry Jack's, these
are our dessert options.
We have a Storm Biscoff,
which wasn't available;
a Storm bubblegum; a Storm Oreo;
a Storm Cadbury Flake;
a Storm M&M's mini; a sticky date pudding;
a caramel sundae; a strawberry sundae;
a chocolate sundae; and a
mini Drumstick, vanilla.
Storms, if you're not too familiar,
I would say it's quite
similar to a McFlurry.
The bubblegum looks a
little bit terrifying.
I really want to try it.
It looks kind of gross.
With the marshmallows on top,
it looks ridiculously sweet.
This is all that I had
to try my ice cream with.
That was so sweet. It
was putrid. It was foul.
I don't even think a
child would like that.
That is ... uh-uh.
You can't go wrong with an
Oreo. I always get them.
But a Flake will be good.
The chocolate is a bit shredded.
That is a bit of me. That
is a bit of me! Mm-hmm.
Nice, creamy, and then a delicious taste
of flaky milk chocolate.
Burst of flavor in your
mouth, not overpowering,
and not feeling like you're
going to have to end up
in the ER because you have a heart attack.
They've even added some more Storm Flakes
to the base of the ice cream. So amazing.
Mm, mm! Mm!
Even though the M&M's have melted,
this is really yum.
M&M's always a good choice.
I like the M&M's Storm.
This is the date, the sticky date.
It's living up to the
Australian name right now.
It's really hot here. We're
just about to get into summer.
And the sticky date did in fact
not make it from the journey
from Hungry Jack's to the studio.
So this is what we've got.
A nice, soggy sticky date.
I've tried a caramel sundae before.
Caramel sundaes are really,
really popular here.
Caramel in general, really popular.
But let's give a
strawberry sundae a crack.
Yeah, just tastes like
a strawberry sundae.
This Drumstick here
actually launched in Australia in 1963.
And Peters is a classic Australian brand.
So this is a national Australian dessert,
one could say.
Lot of US drinks at the BK.
Starting way down there, a
specific bottle of water.
This Pure Life Nestlé water.
I should drink this. I'm not going to.
We also have diet Coke.
I don't like diet.
We have Dr Pepper. Yeah, the doc.
Mm, delicious.
A Minute Maid lemonade.
This is, I believe, root beer.
And other drinks you
can get, for the kids,
a little apple juice.
They have these things,
frozen Fanta wild cherry.
It's normally a slushy that
would've been filled up to here
but has melted.
There's also a frozen Coke.
Same thing, but Coca-Cola-flavored.
It's just a melted mess.
You can get a regular
coffee and an iced coffee.
This is the vanilla one, I think. Hang on.
This is the, yes, the vanilla iced coffee.
Ugh! Ho-ho, God!
It's, like, all vanilla. Too much. Blegh.
Bottle of milk, kind of weird.
But also Burger King has these two shakes.
Oreo shake and a chocolate shake.
Yes, Oreo, like the cookie.
And this shake is so
fantastic, and here's why.
It isn't a vanilla shake with chocolate,
it's the creme-flavor-flavored shake.
Mm. It's so good. Mm!
You can also get a chocolate version too.
A chocolate Oreo shake.
Too chocolaty.
This is the one. This is the best one.
Other drinks you can
get at the BK in the US
that we couldn't get or I
just didn't feel like bringing
is Sprite zero, unsweetened iced tea,
Simply orange juice,
frozen Fanta blue raspberry drink,
Powerade zero, Hi-C fruit punch,
and Mello Yello.
These are the drinks that
we have at Hungry Jack's.
We have vanilla Coke, Fanta raspberry,
Mount Franklin spring
water, Biscoff shake,
bubblegum shake, caramel
shake, strawberry shake,
orange juice, and Keri apple juice.
We have some frozen drinks with bursties,
which come in a few different flavors.
We have frozen Fanta and grape,
frozen Fanta sour watermelon,
frozen Fanta mango,
and frozen Fanta raspberry.
There's also an option to add
bursties to the frozen drinks.
They come in these flavors.
Our spiders come in a
frozen Fanta grape spider,
frozen Fanta sour watermelon spider,
a frozen Fanta mango spider,
a frozen Fanta raspberry spider,
and a frozen Coke spider.
I'm going to go with the raspberry spider.
That's one thing I love
about Hungry Jack's.
Their ice cream is legit.
Like, their ice cream is so thick.
Look at that.
I like that.
I don't like the bursties with it.
The bursties did nothing for me.
It's just a pop of flavor,
but there's nothing ...
it's just a waste, really.
I think the spider tastes great
just with the raspberry Fanta.
I'm sure that in America you
guys have spiders as well,
but you probably don't call it that.
I'm not a fan of the bursties.
I find that a frozen Coke like this,
the ice cream tastes really
good with the Coke on its own.
The added texture and taste
of a burstie was just useless.
It was kind of a throwaway.
It made it less pleasant.
Jack's Cafe menu has a few options.
A cappuccino; a flat white; a latte;
a long black, which wasn't available;
a mocha; hot chocolate; chai latte;
Dilmah tea, fancy;
a miniccino and a piccolo,
which weren't available;
a macchiato and a short black;
an iced long black,
which wasn't available;
a caramel fudge iced
coffee; an iced chocolate;
an iced mocha; and an iced chai.
And for the iced drinks,
there's an option to add
brown sugar popping pearls.
That doesn't sound good
to me,
but I'm going to try it anyway.
It sounds like it's going
to be really, really sweet.
So, we're going to try the
caramel fudge iced coffee.
Oh, my God, I hate it!
I hate their bur — ugh.
Why?
Why ruin a perfectly good iced coffee
with these bursties?
Hungry Jack's,
I really appreciate you
trying to be innovative
and trying to jump on that whole
boba sensation that's happening,
but don't ruin a good thing.
You've got a really good thing going.
Your coffees are great.
Well, they're good.
So, for those of you
who haven't heard of Hungry Jack's before,
it first opened up in
Perth, Australia, in 1971.
You see, Burger King wanted to open
restaurants in Australia,
but the name Burger King
had already been trademarked
by a local restaurant in Adelaide
because Burger King actually
had never trademarked it down under.
A wealthy businessman, Jack Cowin,
acquired the rights to the
Australian Burger King franchise
and decided to name it Hungry Jack's.
Hungry Jack's and Burger King
actually went to court in 2001
due to Burger King wrongfully trying
to terminate an agreement in 1990,
which allowed Hungry
Jack's to open and develop
Burger King franchises in Australia.
The development agreement,
as it was named,
meant Hungry Jack's had to open
a minimum of four restaurants per year
in certain parts of Australia.
Burger King began working with Shell
to market its own restaurant
outlets in Australia,
in a relationship that
excluded Hungry Jack's,
which was not made aware
of this until a year later.
That was in 1995.
In 1995, Burger King withdrew the approval
for third-party franchises to open,
which meant that Hungry Jack's
could not stick to the
development agreement.
Eventually, Hungry Jack's
actually won the battle,
and the judge ruled that Burger King
had been breaching the contract.
An agreement was made
to rebrand the new Burger
King restaurants in Australia
into Hungry Jack's as the
sole master franchise.
Even though Australia is a huge country,
it still doesn't have as many
Hungry Jack's restaurants
compared to the number of Burger
King restaurants globally.
There's only 452 Hungry Jack's,
and that is as of September 2023.
That's right.
There's more than 18,700 Burger King
restaurants around the world.
That's 42 times more than Hungry Jack's.
Texas is actually the state
with the most Burger King restaurants,
at 583 as of September 2023.
This year, however,
two of Burger King's largest franchises
have filed for bankruptcy due
to low sales and high costs,
and Burger King announced
that it will be closing
a few hundred stores later this year.
In August of this year,
Burger King was faced
with a lawsuit over the
size of its Whoppers
compared to what's on the menu.
The lawsuit alleged that the
Whopper looked 35% larger
with more than double the
meat in the advertisement
compared to the Whopper
customers actually received.
In response to the claim,
a spokesperson for Burger King said that
the patties featured in its ads
are the same ones used in the Whoppers
served all over this great nation.
No way that's true, but moving on.
I mean, the fact that Burger King sells
2.1 billion Whoppers every year
tells me the advertisement's working.
So, all right, it's not the same size.
Whatever, you ate it.
Get on with your life.
Hungry Jack's also faced a lawsuit in 2020
when McDonald's tried
to sue over its creation
of the Big Jack, which McDonald's claimed
was very similar to the Big Mac.
I can understand the similarities there.
Both parties were expected
to return to court
at a later date, but the Big
Jack was dropped from the menu,
so it seems the disagreement
may have been resolved.
McDonald's is definitely Hungry
Jack's biggest competitor,
with over 1,000 restaurants,
but word on the street is
Wendy's is going to expand in Australia,
although there has been a mixed response
about that entering here.
McDonald's is the No. 1
competitor against Burger King,
possibly because it has more locations,
about 40,000 more as of 2022,
which is over double the
amount of Burger Kings.
McDonald's has always been larger,
despite both chains starting
around the same year in the 1950s.
McDonald's is just optimized
for business domination.
Burger King, I can't believe
there's this many Burger
Kings, to be honest.
McDonald's is the king.
They do everything right.
They've always done everything right.
Burger King has just been
looking at McDonald's
and trying to copy what they do.
I'm not a big Burger King
fan. I love McDonald's.
McDonald's fries, way
better right out the gate.
The burger selection at
McDonald's, way better.
More convenient, better service.
Yeah, I love Hungry Jack's.
I recently have been
consuming more Hungry Jack's
than any other fast food.
I like Hungry Jack's. The
burgers are really good.
I like the meat. I like the produce.
The good thing about Hungry Jack's is
you can taste the difference
in the quality of meat.
It is definitely far more
superior in the make.
It's a bit more of a step up
from your average cheeseburgers.
I think a lot of Aussies
perceive Hungry Jack's
as something we grew up with.
It definitely, even though
it's the exact same thing as Burger King,
Hungry Jack's for us resembles
something that's Australian
or an Australian take on American burgers
and American fast-food chains.
Let's talk about price.
In Australia, our Whopper
is 9.20 Australian dollars,
which is 6.03 USD.
Make it a meal with medium
fries and a medium Coke,
it'd be 16.40 AUD,
or 10.75 USD.
In the US, a Whopper will cost you $6.89.
That makes our Whopper 2% more expensive.
If you want to make it a meal
with a medium drink,
goozh, and a medium fry,
this whole thing will cost you $12.18.
That's an 18% increase in price.
It looks like our menu
might be a little bit cheaper than the US.
I think the prices at Hungry
Jack's are quite reasonable.
There are a lot of fast-food chains around
that are quite expensive
for what you're getting,
and I always think that
the price at Hungry Jack's
is really quite competitive.
Yeah, you know what?
12-something for this,
that seems like a pretty good deal.
I'm seeing all these news stories about,
fast food is suddenly not cheap anymore.
It used to be a lot less expensive,
but I still think
12-something for all of this,
I could definitely get full on all this.
So, yeah, this is a pretty good deal.
We took a look at the most calorific items
on Hungry Jack's menu.
In Australia, this is the Grill
Masters double cowboy Angus,
coming in at 1,401 calories.
However, if you got
the triple cheeseburger
Super Stunner meal, which
comes with small fries,
a small Coke, a mini Drumstick,
three chicken nuggets,
that would come to 1,386 calories,
which is still less than the burger,
and with 15 calories remaining.
For the US, it's the bacon king
as the most calorific single menu item,
coming in at 1,200 calories.
Let's get the rest of the
stats on the screen there.
If you were to get a cheeseburger meal
with a small fry and a small drink, Coke,
and a four-piece nugget
and a soft-serve cone,
that's only 86 calories more
than just this bacon king.
Unfortunately, US Burger King
does not disclose its
ingredients, online or off.
However, the Hungry Jack's website does
have a full list of ingredients,
and we found some pretty
interesting stuff.
The cheese in the plant-based Whopper
isn't actually fully vegetarian,
as it contains products derived from cows!
More specifically, it
contains calves' rennet,
which is a type of lining of the stomach,
and it's a type of enzyme
commonly used in a lot of cheeses
to help separate the curds and whey
in the cheesemaking process.
Liars! We trusted you!
So if you actually want
to avoid animal products,
be sure to specify "vegan"
Whopper when you order,
not just a "plant-based" Whopper.
A lot of ingredients like
to use big scientific names
which sound a little scary,
such as tocophorovello.
I can't even say that.
Tocopherol. Tocophorol.
But this is just another
word for vitamin E.
Why not just say that?
And it is found in foods
such as vegetable oils,
nuts, and leafy greens.
And we also found in barbecue sauce,
there's Rochester sauce.
I don't even know what
a Rochester sauce is.
I know what a rottweiler is,
and that's a dog.
Rochester sauce, I'm not
too familiar with that.
I am  ... what is that, Hungry Jack's?
Still rolling.
All right.
[groans]
Starting to lose it. It's that time.
Uh-huh. All right!